hey how you doing today folks today I'm
going to continue my plot League
breakdown and most of you are familiar
with this right after Christmas I
received a message about this extended
version of the plot leaked and after I
read it it sounds it interesting enough
to make a video about it and as much
backlash as the original leaked gut this
video currently has like 340 thousand
views which is pretty damn crazy it was
actually well received compared to the
original one at least but no matter how
good or bad it sounds we still have no
idea how much of it will be true until
we actually see the episodes play out
for themselves but I want to go to reach
episode like I have been doing and see
how much of it could actually be true
based off of all the information we have
gotten through filming reports photos
and also characters locations from the
last episodes that they were in and we
might actually be able to find out what
they are likely to do next or at least
possibly could do next so let's begin
season 7 episode 5 was titled the field
of fire and it starts off with John
Davos Gendry and Jorah getting ready to
leave Dragonstone and head north but
beyond stops John and asked him if he
can join them on this mission that way
he can try to repay John for what he has
done in the past
so John allows him to go based off the
photos we have we know for a fact that
John Davos Gendry and Jorah do leave
Dragonstone together on a small boat and
this is going to take place during
episode 4 or 5 because the director
that's there shooting these scenes is
Matt Jackman who is going to be
directing this episode and based off of
other photos we have gotten we do know
that John and fian will have an
interaction on this same Beach and it's
obvious from the photo that John is not
happy with the on which is completely
understandable given what fian did at
Winterfell so I could see Theon wanting
to do something heroic to make up for
what he has done so this really doesn't
sound too crazy at all so far but the
only problem is all the photos we have
seen with John Davos Gendry and Jorah
leaving the beach
Theon Greyjoy is not in any of those so
it doesn't appear that Theon is going to
be on the same boat with them heading
north but that doesn't necessarily mean
he doesn't go because Theon did arrive
on his own boat when he got the
Dragonstone so he could follow them up
in a separate boat that's always
possible but I cannot confirm this in
any way so we're just going to have to
wait and see if Theon does go with them
and if he saw my last spoiler video you
know that there's at least one or two
mysterious characters that are with Jon
Snow and the other guys north of the
wall so Theon could possibly be one of
those people
okay next it says Dany splits her armies
into two groups one Dothraki and one
unsullied
she then marches on King's Landing okay
this is actually possible based off the
photos we have we know for a fact that
the Dothraki and Danny's dragons attack
the Lannister and Tarly forces right
after Jamie takes Highgarden and from
the reports we know that Matt Sheikh
Minh will be directing these scenes so
it is going to take place in this
episode or the one before it and we have
photo as a Jaime randyll Tarly and the
Dothraki all in the same battlefield
preparing for battle and there was also
footage of a dragon attack here too but
we only saw the flames and heard some
screams of someone being burnt alive
because we're probably not going to ever
see any dragons because they're usually
always added in with CGI later so there
is a very good chance that after Danny
defeats their forces here she could head
to King's Landing next especially if she
defeats Jaime in his army which is what
all the reports I've said so far so it
would be a good opportunity for her to
strike King's Landing considering she
takes out Jaime Lannister's force so
that's that's what I would do plus we
know Danny's coming for that throne
anyway so she could strike at any moment
if she wanted to but I'm assuming none
of this is in order because the next
successor angel Tarly and Jaime
Lannister take ty burns weapon that is
used to take down dragons they then
leave King's Landing to battle the
Dothraki
was the reach and western forces okay so
we know it's not going to go down like
this because we know when Jamie fights
the Dothraki it's right after he leaves
Highgarden it's not after he leaves
King's Landing Jamie's not going to be
in King's Landing when he's getting
ready for this battle he's going to be
further south than that but this is
definitely going to happen next season
but some of it is just a little bit out
of order but I can't say whether or not
they're going to have a weapon made to
take down dragons but personally I would
highly recommend that they get one or
make one somehow because without it they
really don't stand a chance against
three big dragons
Qyburn does have a lab so I could see
him coming up with something especially
if Cersei demanded that he makes
something to take down these dragons but
we haven't seen anyone with something
like this in any of the photos so I
really don't know if this is going to
happen but I think it's possible I don't
see why cardboard couldn't make
something I know they're definitely
going to want to but let's move on next
it says Breen and Aria spar at
Winterfell with ghost - Nymeria watching
okay we know Arya is heading home for a
fact she told Jagan agar that herself
and she's getting closer and closer with
each passing episode but I can only
assume Brandt's gonna go back there but
I'm pretty confident that's where she's
going to go we know she went to the
blackfish to try to get help for the
Battle of the bastards she was denied so
she's more than likely going to go back
to Sansa and tell her the bad news but
little does Brienne know that Jon
already won that battle and has
Winterfell back but once Brienne finds
out I guarantee she's going to go back
to protecting Songza because we all know
how loyal bran is in early on during
filming we did get photos of Arya and
Brienne on set during the same day Arya
was wearing her northern type clothes
and Brienne was wearing the same
undergarments that Jon Snow was wearing
that same day on set so there was a very
good chance Arya and Brienne encounter
one another next season and given their
personalities I could see them doing
something like this
because we both know they love to fight
so it's not crazy they would spar with
each other especially if aria is pissed
off that Brienne kicked the hounds ass
we all know how fond Aria was of hound
during the end which is why she didn't
put him out of his misery
she didn't want to kill him at least not
anymore so Aria could show some
resistance again when Brienne shows up
just like she did last time you know she
really hated the Hound she would have
left him one with Brienne but I really
hope we get a scene like this next
season with these two characters I would
really love for them to team up could
you imagine Arya and Brienne going out
together kicking ass I'd be completely
awesome but let's move on next it says
Mira Reid tells brand that she's going
to leave Winterfell
to go back home okay this seems pretty
obvious assuming brain and Muir make it
back South safely last time we saw them
was at the weirwood tree right outside
the wall when brand gave us one of the
biggest revelations in the entire series
during one of his visions he confirmed
for us that Lyanna stark is the in fact
Jon Snow's mother bringing Mira know
that the night's king is coming and he
might be hot on their trail so they're
going to need to get south of the wall
ASAP and Mira and her brother Joe Jon's
mission was to get brand to the
three-eyed raven and now that she was
able to do that once she helps him get
back home her mission is going to be
complete so there will be no reason for
her to be there anymore
unless of course they write something
new into her story but other than that
she would probably go home unless she
stuck around just out of curiosity but
personally I hope we find out something
about her father's whereabouts or
hopefully when she gets home she has her
fault or go to Winterfell to meet up
with bran
since the show has already introduced us
to Howland Reed I think the chances of
him showing back up are pretty damn good
but Mira was seen on set the same day as
other characters who are already in
Winterfell even though that doesn't mean
she was filming with them it does give
me hope that they do make it to
Winterfell and have some scenes with
those same characters so I'm pretty
confident Brian and Mira are going to
make it
the winter fell and I think most of you
would agree with that okay moving on
it says the Hound tells songs of that
little finger betrayed her father so
saws that comes up with a plan to take
revenge against Littlefinger so she
agrees to marry him but it makes arya
mad
so arya leaves and the scene cuts a wave
of her songs that can tell Aria about
her plan all right I may end up being
wrong about this and I and if I am I
will have no problem admitting that if I
do but I think this part sounds like
[ __ ] to me I'm not going to say it's
impossible I would never really say that
but it just doesn't feel right to me
this really doesn't feel like little
finger style
I think he's way more calculated than
having to force her to marry him but
that's just my opinion but one thing I
could see is the Hound telling songs of
what happened to her father that day the
Hound was present in the throne room the
day Littlefinger put the blade in its
throat which led to his imprisonment and
ultimate death
we know that the Hound is very fond of
songs on hand Arya Sanjay is his little
bird who we know he is willing to
protect and now that the Hound is on
this Avengers tour killing any piece of
[ __ ] he comes in contact with I could
see him wanting to weed out Littlefinger
if given the chance but I don't know if
it's going to go down like this
I'm not really sure if the Hound is
gonna even be in Winterfell next season
at all
there have been no photos or reports of
him being there nor has he been seen
with any of the characters while they
are there but there's always a chance of
that surprise which I would like to get
but I know someone who will be in
Winterfell soon and who will not be
putting up with any of little fingers
[ __ ] and that is Brienne of Tarth
one of the greatest fighters in all of
Westeros Brienne does not like
Littlefinger at all remember when Sean's
a met Littlefinger in moles town
remember when songs that kept trying to
remind him of what Ramsay did to her
and she kept asking him if he knew how
she was treated but Littlefinger would
have respond Brienne had her hand on the
handle of her sword and she demanded
Littlefinger to speak she said lady
Sansa
asked you a question she dared
Littlefinger not to speak she was ready
to execute him right there of songs I
had only given her the word
so when Breen and Podrick make it back
to Winterfell to protect Sansa
I think if Breen even gets a hint of
Littlefinger trying to betray her again
she will cut his ass down but I think
there are a lot of ways he can die next
season even like the original League
said where it says that Arya will
execute him I could see that going down
Littlefinger isn't on her list but if
she finds out what he did to her father
he will quickly be added to the list and
quickly removed from the list without
hesitation and I also think that songs
that can reveal that Littlefinger was
the one who killed her on Liza all of
the backstabbing that Littlefinger has
done over the years was going to come
back at him and be his downfall
guaranteed it's going to eventually
catch up to him you cannot run that
forever but I just don't see him forcing
her to marry him but believe me when I
say this as soon as Jon Snow leaves for
Dragonstone Littlefinger scheming will
be again at full force but let's just
hope Sansa has learned from her mistakes
and is able to counter any move that he
makes ok next it says Sam finds out that
Jon's real name is Aegon he then leaves
old town before euron greyjoy
consecutive place I think we can all
agree this sounds like complete
horseshit everyone knows that Rhaegar
Targaryen already had a son named Aegon
so the chances of him naming another son
the same thing is very unlikely and
sounds a bit ridiculous so let's just
not waste any of our time and move on
from this part ok the Brotherhood
without banners leave Winterfell and
head towards the wall and they are with
tormund and Brienne Thoros has a vision
of a battle in the snow taking place
beyond the wall ok we have yet to
receive any proof that the Brotherhood
ever goes to Winterfell so I can only
speculate whether this is going to
happen or not
but what we do know is that members of
the Brotherhood do go on a mission with
John and a few other characters later in
the season and one of those characters
is tormund Giantsbane and since tormund
did not go to Dragonstone with john then
i think there is that chance that
torment could meet up with the
Brotherhood before he meets up with John
then that that could be how they all end
up meeting up together for this mission
and we also have a photo of torment and
an island together and we know that the
Hound was last seen with the Brotherhood
and is more than likely still traveling
with them for the entire season
considering they are together for a
scene that's taken place during episode
six next season but I think torment is
actually going to meet up with them
somewhere else torment and the
Brotherhood are probably going to meet
up at the wall I think before John
leaves Dragonstone he's probably going
to tell torment about his plan to go
beyond the wall so I'm sure Horman's
going to meet him there but this is just
a guess now I can't say whether Brienne
is going to go we haven't received
really any information on Brienne during
the off season the only photo I have
seen during the during the off season
was at the beginning stages of filming
and that's the same photo you saw
earlier when she was on set with all the
other characters in the north but there
is a chance that bran could be one of
those mysterious characters that has
gone with them beyond the wall she's a
complete badass indefinitely someone I
would want to take given that she can
probably beat all of these other
characters up in a fight so I wouldn't
be mad if the script actually put this
in there and set her but that would just
mean that Songza has even less
protection with her while she is with
Littlefinger at Winterfell
so that could end up being a
double-edged sword but let's move on it
says the first battle of the Queen's
begin the reach forces are defeating the
unsullied due to randall tarly's
commanding archers who have the Sun at
their back the three forces collide with
Lannister forces nearby bran kills two
Dothraki Jaime kills one Jaime appears
to be winning the battle until drove on
and rague all appear ray gall kills
Randall and dicken Tarly
dragon fire Kai burns weapon hurt ragle
but then Drogo and destroys the weapon
throw gone nearly kills Jamie but bran
saves him just in time can I just say
that this sounds [ __ ] awesome
Lannister and Tarly burst with rocky and
unsullied plush dragons and the open
field I am all in for this scene and the
good thing is we already know that most
of this is going to happen there have
been dozens of reports and dozens of
photos that have came out as they have
been filming this battle scene we know
there are over 500 extras and a hundred
horses being trained for this battle
which is pretty much more than what they
used at the Battle of the bastards
I think this scene is going to be
incredible we have seen photos of the
Lannister and Tarly army side-by-side
and we have also seen the Dothraki army
marching in and there was also photos
and videos of them setting up a
flamethrower to use his dragon fire and
in the video you can hear a man
screaming Konishi so there are going to
be some serious casualties of war here
and if Jamie is almost killed by a
dragon after he loses the majority of
his forces he's going to reconsider who
he is fighting for knowing this is a war
he cannot win fighting for a woman he
may no longer even love I think this
battle scene is going to be a major
turning point for who has the power in
Westeros and we all know who is going to
come up out on top now I cannot wait to
see this battle scene I have no idea if
Qyburn has created any kind of weapon to
use against the dragon but it would be
wise and it would be cool as hell if he
did that would just add an extra layer
to this battle knowing that the dragons
can be hurt too so I actually hope we
get to see something like this if we
don't see a horn I think there needs to
be some kind of an equaliser for these
dragons or else we're never going to
have to worry about Daenerys going into
battle which could get boring if we know
she's never going to lose think about it
but there's one last part to this
episode that says Jaime arrives back in
King's Landing after the battle and he
told Cersei she should surrender but
Cersei refuses
sits on the Iron Throne again there is
no way to confirm this but like I just
said after Daenerys defeats the
lannister and Tarly forces and if she
does nearly kill Jaime with one of her
dragons he is going to need to
reconsider what the hell he is doing
they are running out of people to align
themselves with and eventually they will
have nowhere to run so I do think Jaime
will come up with an exit strategy
before Cersei does Cersei is never going
to surrender nor will she ever bend the
knee you're going to have to kill her to
get her off that Iron Throne and with
that I'm going to end this here so thank
you guys for listening and I will see
you next time bye